let's go next to our caller from the 662
area code who's calling today from six
six two hey David
yes hey David I have a quick question
for you okay just hold on one second
let's see if we can clean up the
connection a little bit are we on
speakerphone right now we are okay
sorry airpipe I thought that was okay
okay
very good I and there was good it seems
like whatever noise was happening in the
background has been resolved who's this
where are you calling from
uh this is Ross of Kahn from Denver
Colorado great what's going on today hey
I think it's a lot of tympole and he's
thinking that a lot of people are lying
to the pollsters about Biden and
thinking they're just like sitting
really gonna vote for Claud there's like
it's silent majority especially with
like his economic Gribble rating is
alike at 58% just wanted to know what
your thoughts were on that I haven't
I mean I've not seen this assertion made
I don't I don't know what Tim is saying
I think you have to defend such an
assertion with evidence and merely
pointing to higher economic approval
then support for Trump wouldn't really
be evidence it could just as easily be
evidence that despite feeling that
things are okay economically people
still are going to vote for Biden over
Trump like we're it's it's one of these
it's an indie feasible argument you
can't possibly make a counter point
because implicitly it's that people are
not telling the truth
so if by deaf if your argument is people
or lying we wouldn't be able to disprove
that until people actually vote in
November so we kind of have to just wait
and see okay but I think it also
happened in 2016 I think people are
ashamed to say hey I'm a not not a trump
supporter by minimum in what sense that
it happened in to hold on whatever we
have to happen late 2016 what that what
evidence do we have that it it happened
in 2016 oh because everyone thought that
it was gonna be a blowout bakery for
Hillary I mean like the New York Times
what was it
are the Huffington Post over the 93
percent chance it was going to win okay
no but let's so these are we're now I
think this is a good opportunity to to
think about some of these things in a
couple different ways so there are times
I think said on election day that it was
like a 70% chance that Hillary won now
what you know that when they say that
they're not predicting Hillary gets 70
percent of the votes
a 70 percent chance to win means that if
you run a hundred elections with the
inputs we had in 70 of them Hillary
would win and in 30 Trump would win so
that part you understand right yeah okay
good so then the second part is the
polling on election day was that Hillary
was ahead nationally by 3.2 and she won
by two point one which is within the
margin the stated margin of error so the
national polls were were correct in 2016
okay but I just really think the
Democrats are playing with fire when
they're talking about defunding the
police when there's like a poll that
came out that like 88 percent of people
are satisfied with the police or either
one more funding and only like 12
percent want to defund employees right
so now but so now you you're now making
a totally different argument your first
argument was that in 2016 people lied
about supporting Hillary now you're
saying defund the police is a bad idea
you're acknowledging we're now on to
something different right yeah okay now
I agree with you I'm I think that the I
don't know if you saw my clip but the
poll I saw says only 16 percent of the
country supports defund I think it's the
wrong messaging I've put out a much more
specific plan that is about demilitarize
and retrain and Rhee delegate and stuff
like that so on this issue I agree with
you but under the issue that in 2016
people lied about supporting Hillary the
data don't back that up all right maybe
I'll have to look more into it but David
I appreciate your column will bit more
on the right but I do use your show to
get a more balanced perspective and I
appreciate what you do ma'am all right
thank you for the call very much
appreciate it I think hopefully we were
able to resolve a few factual
misunderstandings there I ventured